few own territory uh vast swath of land
you're doing nothing to it but he
doesn't know that he's lying other I
mean I can't imagine anybody being that
ignorant or that stupid for that matter
and someone comes and squats on it and
spends a lot of time improving it your
Muslim listeners they don't have Alexa
Alexa was built for about 1500 years ago
who built it at some point they actually
develop a valid legal claim to the
property itself I do not understand this
infatuation with a man who has been
indicted for corruption and is a known
war criminal I'm saying something else
though I'm saying that they held the
land for two thousand years were kicked
out because these people want to see
Alexa destroyed they want to see the
Dome of the Rock destroyed and they want
to build something else there instead
they took over my apartment okay a long
time ago
they stole it they stole like I said the
produce from the fields they stole money
in the banks there were Banks people had
money in the banks they had these
Orthodox Jews walking the streets and
this Rabbi said the first thing I'll do
is I would ask the Palestinians to come
back
and the student says why what are you
talking about they're terrorists they
want to kill us
and the rabbi his name is Rabbi amram
Rabbi amaran Blau and the rabbi said who
told you that
who told you that the Arabs were going
to kill us we had great relations with
the Muslims and the Arabs back in the
day when Palestine is free people like
him are going to be ashamed that they
did this he's going to be embarrassed
that he did this
and his final messages
show
so now making greetings of Peace how you
guys doing welcome to the dean show and
my next guest Miko Pilla is an Israeli
American activist author and karate
instructor he's the author of the book
General's son a journey of an Israeli in
Palestine and Injustice his grandfather
was one of the original signers of the
Declaration of Independence his father
was the General for an Israeli Army he
is one of the best qualified individuals
to talk about this topic and in this
case to give an official response to the
recent interview that Jordan Peterson
had with PM elect Benjamin nikolski or
is it AKA Netanyahu and after this
interview of ours if Jordan Jordan
Peterson is really a man out for any
truth you'll see this man my next guest
Miko pillitt on his show with your
petition and voice let's bring out Miko
pilot Miko how are you doing good good
to be with you again my friend I want to
thank you for taking this interview on
such short notice I know you're very
busy and I appreciate that let's get uh
right into it I want to start off with
your response to the recent interview if
you own territory uh vast swath of
landed you're doing nothing to it and
someone comes and squats on it and
spends a lot of time improving it at
some point they actually develop a valid
legal claim to the property itself and
so it there seems to be something
intrinsic to our notion of valid
ownership that if you're going to occupy
a territory you actually have to do
something with it that's productive and
so that's that's at least part of the
claim you're making at the moment to
buttress the notion that the Jewish
people have a valid claim to the present
territory
there were a lot of movement back and
forth but but the Jews have actually
taken the land and made something of it
well I'm saying something else though
I'm saying that they held the land for
two thousand years were kicked out the
Arabs came and conquered it and
immediately lost it to others and did
nothing with it the others did nothing
with it so it was basically they took
over my apartment okay a long time ago
the the guys who took over who basically
kicked me out were kicked out themselves
the apartment was left Barren and many
decades in this case centuries later I
come back to this mess okay this ruin
and I build it up back and I not only
improve it I not only make my ownership
based on Improvement but then nobody
else did anything with it there was
there was no someone else there
practically were no tenants there that's
my argument you got a chance to uh
listen and watch the interview Miko
pilling
yeah you know I don't understand this
infatuation that Americans have with
Benjamin Netanyahu I mean he was on
Peterson's show he was on Bill Marsh
show he was on the networks recently
talking about all kinds of things
including Russia he was on Joel Osteen's
uh show he's got this mega church I do
not understand this infatuation with a
man who has been indicted for corruption
and is a known war criminal he's got
more blood on his hands and I think
almost you know that anybody could
possibly even imagine he is a he you
know he is
um you know anti-arab anti-muslim uh
anti-christian for that matter when if
the Christians are are uh our
Palestinians of course and um excuse me
and I do not understand the infatuation
with this man what is it that they find
in him why do they allow him to spew
these ridiculous ridiculous lies I mean
anyone with with uh a little bit of
common sense
um Can can refute all of those
ridiculous arguments that he just made
made about about the land being Barren
and empty and the Jews holding it for
all these this is complete nonsense this
historically this is a historical
nonsense and the problem is not the
Netanyahu is spewing these arguments
because you know he's the one that you
know he's he he's the criminal but why
are they allowing him why is Jordan
Peterson allowing him why is Bill Maher
allowing him why are the networks
allowing this criminal and they don't
even challenge him fine you're going to
interview a guy like that challenge him
challenge him on the truth challenge him
about his corruption charges he was
indicted challenging him about the fact
that he is been he for for more than a
decade he was he was governing he was
prime minister of Israel winning
horrific war crimes and abuses of Human
Rights against the Palestinians were
taking place that is the problem the
problem is the people interviewing him
not challenging him and allowing him or
giving him a platform to continue these
lies knowing fully well that he's lying
there's no way anybody but he doesn't
know that he's lying other I mean I
can't imagine anybody being that
ignorant or that stupid for that matter
so this is the problem it's if the
Americans have this infatuation with
this man and they're allowing him
they're giving him a platform he's not
even the Prime Minister yet he hasn't
been sworn in yet he was elected but he
hasn't been sworn in yet so this is what
I believe is the is the is the issue
here
so you said anyone with a little bit of
common sense if you look at his track
record somebody who was indicted who's
known to lie and now he's kind of making
up his own history here
someone with some common sense can go
and do some research and they can
themselves unfold all of these uh how
many lies do we have here well it's
impossible to count I mean we could
spend days hours and hours refuting
every single eye it's all based on life
the entire premise that somehow uh
Jewish people have a right have a right
some kind of a right to Palestine is
first of all is absurd but historically
um you know to say that there was
nothing in Palestine for two thousand
years Palestinians have built cities and
towns and an economy and a culture
um and agriculture all of this time I
mean your Muslim listeners they don't
have Alexa Alexa was built for about
1500 years ago who built it who'd cared
for it who's maintained It This
Magnificent magnificent structure and if
anybody has not has not uh been to
Jerusalem and seen it they I strongly
encourage people to to fly there and see
it and to and to pray there and it's a
magnificent structure who built it who
built the cities of tabaria of Haifa who
built these cities
you mentioned there was one city I think
in the interview one city so that right
there this is for Jordan Peterson I'm
sure he'll watch this God willing he'll
watch this and now he's got to look at
the facts if there's any ounce of
conscious his soul is awake you know
he's a person a principal of some
Integrity we're giving facts you can go
look it up so this is the person that he
decided to bring on he didn't challenge
him and now you're given these facts
this is this is academically people can
go look this up now so he mentioned
something about it was I believe it was
like one city you're naming a bunch of
cities here that were developed were
there Farmers there were ports please
explain this to us we've been told that
they're out to kill us all
assalamualaikum brothers and sisters we
went to the streets to ask Americans
about Islam here's what they said do you
know anything about Islam No do you know
anything about Islam No sadly do you
know anything about Islam uh not really
do you know anything about Islam
no sorry you know what Islam means Islam
uh no we've been told that they're out
to kill us all that's what you've been
told that Muslims are out to kill you
all
well that's what they say on TV
anything
I know it's in the Middle East isn't it
well then you can have four wives
brothers and sisters as you can see
there are so many Americans who don't
know about Islam we need your help to
change that help us to build the dean
Center the first mega dawa Center in
America click to donate right now may
God Almighty Allah reward all of you
foreign
Palestine you know there's a claim that
the zionists came or the Jews came and
made the desert bloom in Palestine
they stole a country that was in full
bloom they stole entire cities they
stole produce from the fields Palestine
Palestinians were exporting uh cotton
they were exporting olive oil they were
exporting uh um barley from the neck up
in the desert well you know it's a very
you know the desert in the south I mean
Palestine was a thriving economy the
cities
all of these cities were already in
existence and most of them were actually
built by Palestinians uh during the
Muslim time some were built even before
that the city of Gaza you know has been
inhabited for you know thousands of
years these were cultural they were
there was cultural centers universities
schools hospitals homes like I said an
industry in agriculture they came and
they stole a country that was blooming
and then they had the the audacity to
say they made the Desert Bloom that is
complete nonsense if there's any Legacy
to what the Israelis did to Palestine is
destruction and again Jordan Peterson by
the way was visited Palestine recently
and he went on a tour in Alexa but with
his Jewish settlers with Zionist
settlers he took a tour of Alexa
desecrating uh Alexa with these live
violent racist Liars he did that with
Ben Shapiro you know and they were they
were hosted by these by these settlers
who want to see by the way Alexa burn
but that's a whole other story and to
build some kind of a hoax I don't know
some kind of a temple that they you know
but I mean that this is terrible he also
have the Israeli Ambassador former
Israeli Ambassador on uh Derma there
before on his on his show I you know
this this constant desire to promote
these lies is the problem and Americans
willingness to listen to them and accept
them and not challenge these people that
is I think a very serious problem if you
want to be fair and balanced how
difficult or not so difficult would it
be for Jordan Peterson take another trip
and to go just cross over how many
minutes of how long is the journey for
him to go and speak to the people on the
ground
and to get a get the other side he was
there Palestinians are everywhere all he
had to do was go with the you know yeah
yeah so he's there he all he has to I
mean to go into someone's house to sit
with the locals to sit with some of the
some of the people there be a Christian
Palestinians uh Muslim Palestinians
people on the ground how hard would that
be it's not hard at all
I mean the easiest thing in the world
there's nothing hard about it there's
nothing obviously
um he did he do that on that trip no no
okay the fact that he was willing to go
on Alexa were settlers with Zionist
settlers who's whose objective is very
clearly stated by the way these settlers
are now going to be in the next Israeli
government which is extremely dangerous
extremely dangerous because because
these people want to see Alexa destroyed
they want to see the Dome of the Rock
destroyed and they want to build
something else there instead based on
some you know uh ancient mythology the
point is that it is extremely dangerous
that these people are being given that
Netanyahu is being given a platform
where millions of people are watching
this and and for some reason nobody
challenges nobody challenges his lies
nobody challenges this this mythical
narrative accept an invitation from
Jordan Peters we opened up the show and
we are going to have people out there
who are watching us to petition to go
ahead and be a voice to go ahead and
push this to get this to Jordan Peterson
to bring on why wouldn't he bring
someone who's one of the most qualified
people to talk about this someone who's
an Israeli an American who has such a
profound history in that area would you
be willing to accept invitation to go on
Jordan Peterson's show I guess of course
I would
um the the question is what are his
motivations if his motivation is to is
to show what what you know to tell the
truth then then of course you know I'd
be happy to to uh uh to be on the show
but my my fear is that both he and all
the others that I mentioned that have
been interviewing Netanyahu are not
interested in the truth they're
interested in promoting this uh
Narrative of Lies for all kinds of
reasons that is the problem of course
I'd be I'd be happy to to to come out to
come you know to come on these shows and
and and and describe or their plenty
Palestinians you know as well that they
could that he could invite and would
describe and and very clearly show that
what Netanyahu was saying is all lies
it's complete fabrication Palestine was
a thriving country and they stole it and
they destroyed it and they kicked out
almost you know and they kicked out and
continued to kick out the population
here are a few other things that um were
brought up that Arabs actually migrated
and then became Palestinians
well everybody at one point and migrated
from one place to another and became
something so it's not like you know
Palestine didn't exist until recently
that Palestine did not exist the Arabs
came then Palestine so here's so here's
what I suggest okay there's an excellent
book by historian
called Palestine a four thousand year
history
um it's all there he showed very clearly
that the ancient Egyptians the Assyrians
uh the Greeks and on and on and on every
every you know every great Empire that
ever ruled that area
referred to that country by the name of
Palestine or some you know some versions
of the name Palestine and this is a
historian who's near who's uh academics
shows Aristotle Aristotle called it
Palestine he shows Herodotus called it
Palestine he shows the Egyptians who
call this Palestine his name is the book
is called the book is called Palestine a
four thousand year history
you know and the thing is the problem is
that often when people talk about the
history of Palestine they go back 75
years they go back 100 years go back 4
000 years like this like like it's a
very cool for a thousand years yeah and
he shows very clearly that Philistine
was referred to by that name
going back almost 4 000 years by all the
different Empires it was and he shows
you know of course you know Empires come
and go and and and and populations
that happened in Europe it's like saying
well the French are not French or I
don't know who is that's not the point
the point is the Palestine and
Palestinians were in existence who are
thriving they were building everywhere
from the from the south and Gaza and and
and the Bedouin in the southern part of
the country all the way to the north to
the Galilee of course Jerusalem you know
you know the reports of akka has been a
well-known Port going back uh throughout
history and this had nothing to do with
Jews it has that had to do with local
Palestinian population there were Jews
there were Christians there were
Armenians but for the the bulk of the
last uh 15 1600 years
Palestine has been an Arab Muslim
country and it was thriving this whole
notion that there was nothing there is
is a fabric complete fabrication and not
only is the fabrication
in 1948 when the Zionist conquered
Palestine they stole it they stole like
I said the produce from the fields they
stole money in the banks there were
Banks people had money in the banks
people working people there was an
economy they stole millions of dollars
worth of money they stole cars they
stole buildings hospitals entire cities
can you imagine they come in they kick
out the people and there are cities yeah
for Haifa like I said all these cities
that I mentioned
um that I mentioned earlier
not to mention you know I mean these
cities some of these cities go back uh
you know as far back in history as we
can as we can uh as we can even look up
but it's very clear that there's a
complete Fabrication in order to justify
the crime of theft and killing
and this they do supposedly in the name
of Jewish people
tell me uh is it when you look into the
migration that happened with many of the
PMS there like uh Netanyahu was
originally his grandfather's name
milanowski and many of the other PMS
they changed their names they migrated
for places like Poland from Russia from
other places all of our all of our
grandparents immigrated and Nathaniel
was a little bit older than I am his
parents immigrated my grandparents
immigrated throughout the last hundred
years that's when we that's where the
designers came to Palestine and they
they did they have different last names
oh yeah they are theirs many many of the
people changed their names my father too
I mean many of the uh the Jews that came
to Palestine and part of their narrative
was to change their name from kind of
Jewish European perhaps or even Jewish
Arab sounding names to this new thing
which is an Israeli name which sounds
different you know and so they they call
it hepatizing hebrewizing the name they
do it into cities they do it to streets
they do it they did the entire country
they do to Palestine and they renamed it
Israel
and so they took their own names you
know sometimes Jewish names that have a
very long and interesting history back
in Europe where they where they came
from that goes back a very long time and
they and they changed it completely
disconnecting themselves from their own
Jewish history by the way
and you see it's very very interesting
because
um when you talked a lot of them you've
talked to a lot of uh people on the
ground there the Palestinians uh you
don't see much migration Just Happening
maybe from one Village to another city
in that area but you know people are
great grandfathers uh their lineage it's
all linked back to Palestine they're
they're I mean let me tell you a story I
you know I was born and raised in
Jerusalem my grandparents you know came
as colonizers in in the 1920s
and so I am you know I'm I'm a dual
citizen I was an Israeli citizenship and
I can go and I've been gone for a long
time but I can go back and live there
tomorrow if I wanted to a Palestinian I
have Palestinian friends whose families
in Jerusalem go back 800 years go back
to the days of salahuddin sometimes
sometimes even before that it's
constantly the same family in the same
part of the city going back that far
back
if they leave now they do not have
citizenship
they have an alien residence kind of
something similar to an alien resident
like a green card they're not even
citizens and if they leave
for more than a couple of years they
can't come back and their property is
taken their families have been there
imagine 800 years in Jerusalem or back
to the days of Jerusalem and they do not
have the same rights as I do
you know like I said my parents came to
colonize less than 100 years ago or 100
years ago so I mean that is how deep the
the racism is there and the problem is
that they need to justify it and the
only way to justify it is to make these
absurd claims that somehow this was ours
and we came back like we we personally
were there 2000 years ago and now we are
back we have some kind of a claim you
know it's historically absurd it's
morally wrong it's but it's politically
you know that's how they push forward
with their agenda which is a political
agenda
and then you you have uh the squatter
argument and it has me thinking like if
you can imagine somewhere like Texas
where someone might own thousands of
acres and they just use up maybe one
acre to have you know a couple acres to
maybe have their house and you know some
other things but they leave the rest of
it it's out there so someone comes into
the person's backyard of thousands of
acres and now because when Jordan
Peterson opened up he was like trying to
cite some kind of English or law or
something of that uh Essence and saying
if you're not doing anything with the
land then you lose the land and that's
how the picture was painted you know so
then I started thinking about this I
mean nobody would accept that that you
have all this acreage you have all of
this you know things are developing but
maybe you might be not using everything
but just because it's in your backyard
and now imagine if someone did that to
you and came in and started to you know
build on it you didn't use that part of
the land and now they have a
justification to take the rest
was even more absurd is the claim that
somehow the land belongs to the Jews
it's an absurd claim it's just it's a
it's an absurd claim it's an absolute
even according to Jewish law
even according to Jewish law and you've
had and you've had uh you know some of
our Ultra Orthodox uh Rabbi friends
Rabbi wise I know you've had on the show
he will tell you Jewish law prohibits
Jews from
sovereignty from claiming the Holy Land
This is a complete nonsense just because
there's there's there are these stories
and there was the existence of a Jewish
minority a minority of Jewish people who
did live in Palestine for a long time
ago as a small minority
you know as a small minority who lived
there this is a ridiculous claim that
somehow this belonged to the Jews and
the Jews were kicked out and the Jews
come back is completely false it has
absolutely no bearing legally there's no
bearing historically it's it's Hocus
Pocus it's it's talking about Santa
Claus you know it's it's just as crazy
as talking about as though Santa Claus
was was real or something wow that's uh
very very interesting Jordan Peterson oh
he's an academic I mean it's somebody
who's not he's intelligent this doesn't
take a lot of research for Jordan
Peterson to look this up or his audience
but it's a shame that many people see
this and now they won't research and
they'll take this myth and all this
falsehood and uh some people many people
run with it but sincere people will go
ahead and look this up and hopefully
they'll have you on the program tell me
this we're Jews and Christians because
another claim you made was that uh
people who conquered this land before he
mentioned byzantinian the Romans he
mentioned people who conquered it didn't
kick the Jewish people out but the the
Muslims came kicked the people the most
the kicked the Jews out and that's
absolutely that's absolutely false
absolutely false I had a rabbi Weiss you
mentioned he also said that Muslims and
Jews are living in peace they were
living there not only not only is it
false but when conquered Jerusalem he
allowed the Jews to continue and pray in
places that the Christians did not allow
them yes and the Muslims that when they
when they when they uh when they came to
Palestine they gave the Jews more rights
and the two Jews with more respect than
the than the Crusaders did of course you
know I mean but I mean this has nothing
to do you know trying to use that as
some kind of a link to to giving the
right to Israel to to exist and maintain
this brutality against the Palestinians
even if it was all true it still
wouldn't justify what Israel is doing to
the Palestinians listen to complete and
total theft and and killing of people on
on a wholesale basis you know even if
all this was true and it's not true but
even if it was to it still would not
justify any of what Israel uh Israel
claims to be you know that to be their
right you know it's it's a it's a
terrible tragedy and again I'm trying to
link it back to to the Bible and trying
to get back to you know ancient history
is is completely false
we'll see on your Twitter feed you have
uh some posts and you see many of these
Orthodox Jews walking the streets that's
right and they're actually holding
Palestinian Flags that's interesting you
know there's a famous Rabbi who lived in
Jerusalem he was one of the uh
anti-zionist rabbis like uh Rabbi Weiss
that you interviewed and he was
interviewed by a student of his and the
student said to him if
um
uh if you were in charge today will be
the first thing that you would do
and this Rabbi said the first thing I
would do is I would ask the Palestinians
to come back
and the student says why what are you
talking about they're terrorists they
want to kill us
and the rabbi his name is Rabbi amram
Rabbi amaran Blau and the rabbi said who
told you that who told you that the
Arabs were going to kill us we had great
relations with the Muslims and the Arabs
back in the day you know his family
lived in Hebron and this half family
lived in Jerusalem that always had you
know Jewish minorities he said we had
great relations we shared the same
values we shared this similar culture
you know we all treat each other with
respect it was only only when the
zionists came
the beginning of the 20th century that
the terrorism began that the violence
began and it was initiated not by the
Palestinians not by the Arabs and the
Muslims but by the zionists
wow this and this was repeat who was
this man again this is the famous Rabbi
who lived in Jerusalem he passed away
already his name was Rabbi amram and uh
the rabbi yeah very well known very
well-known Rabbi who's tested there are
so many there was uh conferences in New
York and you see these videos with
thousands of thousands of Orthodox Jews
educational lesson lectures given by
experts in Judaism about Judaism in
particular the incompatibility between
Judaism and Zionism many Jews believe
wrongly that Zionism is either part of
Judaism or is compatible with Judaism or
is even
the main part of Judaism all of those
are actually false
Zionism was created to negate Judaism
Zionism was created to replace Judaism
the differences between Zionism Judaism
are vast they are vast and profound the
propaganda that the zionists have turned
out for the past hundred years
have confused and conflated Zionism and
Judaism such that when the average
person walks down the street he thinks
that the state of Israel is the Jewish
State he thinks that Zionism is Judaism
and he doesn't know the difference this
group of Jews here are students of the
students of the late Saturday
who was the greatest disseminator of the
clarity regarding the difference between
Judaism and Zionism and you would think
that the media would report on this but
they don't
not at all there's uh before we conclude
just a couple more points uh you also
people can go look this up uh on your
Twitter handle you have a Twitter here
that it uh talks about the Israeli media
lie this is a quote uh the Israeli media
lies and Israelis want to be lied to
this is an interesting thing the
consumers the readers and the viewers
don't want to hear and don't want to
know but glidon Levy uh has been telling
the truth for Doug this is another
Israeli uh yeah
on my uh on my podcast and um yeah you
know he's a very interesting man he's a
great journalist and he's been reporting
he's one of maybe
two reporters Israeli reporters who
actually reports truthfully it's really
really believe that the IDF is the most
moral army in the world
the Israeli media is playing this
shameful role of collaborating with the
occupation the government the Army the
secret Services don't want you to tell
and the consumers the readers and the
viewers don't want to hear and don't
want to know and they someone will ask
what happened here how come this Society
is living in this denial I try to
whistle in the darkness I don't see it
as any influence on the contrary you see
that everything goes to the opposite
direction so what's the point I remember
I asked my father the same question one
day he said well I don't want them to be
able to say that they didn't know yeah
and I cannot say they didn't know
in the Israeli media but Israelis are
not interested I'll give you another
example you know there's a movie that
just came out is on Netflix called farha
it's a Palestinian it's a movie about
Palestine
yeah I just came out Israelis are going
nuts about it because it's telling a
story a true story based on a true story
about a girl and her experience of what
happened to her in her Village in 1948.
it's a very difficult movie to watch
it's an excellent movie excellent movie
uh the director you recommend Jordan
Peterson watch this movie
I doubt that he watched it and I I don't
know if you you recommend he watches and
others who want to they have you have to
like watching uh movies Netflix it's a
very good movie the Israelis like I said
I want to boycott it they want to
boycott and Netflix whatever it's in the
poor move but Israelis are going crazy
about the fact that this one movie
one movie is a true story of a young
lady and how would she experienced in
1948 now she's a refugee living you know
outside of Palestine sadly and so they
do not want to see the truth they do not
want to hear the truth and this is what
Levy said to me when I interviewed him
he said they do not want the truth and I
you know I go there but I go back there
a lot when I listen to the Israeli news
channels you know on TV it's all com
there's nobody's challenging The
Narrative there's no voice of dissent
everybody's agreeing everybody wants to
see more Palestinians die everybody
wants to see more Palestinian Latin
taken it's really very it's really
tragic and it's tragic the people like
Jordan Peterson give a platform to a
criminal like Benjamin Netanyahu that
should really be the bottom line all
right we're out of time tell me uh just
uh last closing comments for the person
uh who's out there who's confused they
want to know they watch that interview
they're watching this they want to know
more uh what else could we I mean we've
uncovered many of the lies and if
someone builds their case on a lie you
know the history of him being indicted
and you have so many uh he was charged
and you got so much baggage you know
here you know of lies and lies built and
then here A whole history of Lies it's
not history it's his history and you
dismantle many of these arguments and
now for someone out there what advice do
you have for the average American you
said with their infatuation with this
this person they're bringing them on all
these shows what do you have to say to
them before we give the final message to
Jordan Peterson well Americans give 3.8
billion dollars to Israel for absolutely
no good reason it's the biggest foreign
aid package any country gets
um and Americans need to know what is
being done with their money and why it's
being sent they need to be educated so
you know there's your show they can go
on mecopilla.com there's articles and
interviews and videos they can you know
they can sign on to my podcast there's
lots of stuff there's lots of books they
should definitely if they're interested
in history the the book I mentioned
Palestine a 4 000 year history
um is an excellent history book
um you know there's there's so much
material out there that's actually very
easy to educate yourself today it's very
easy to educate yourself today and then
talk to Palestinians and I encourage
everybody I encourage everybody to visit
Palestine
take take a trip visit Palestine yeah
yeah and uh Jordan Peterson what would
you say to him
I would I would I would say to him that
it's time to stop giving a platform to
war criminals and Liars if he wants to
if he wants to you know
you know when Palestine is free people
like him are going to be ashamed that
they did this he's going to be
embarrassed that he did this and so
right now he has an opportunity to
remedy that he has an opportunity to
remedy that he can interview me he can
interview you know a whole host of
people excellent people that are out
there that will will tell it the way it
is and that's what he needs to do that's
what he needs to do and not only will he
redeem his own reputation you know
because right now I believe that this
his issue his take on Palestine is is
ruining his reputation but all not only
that he will actually contribute
to the truth being told and he will
contribute to the freedom and liberation
of Palestine
thank you very much Amigo pill I know
you um are very busy thank you for
taking the time to be with us God bless
you always a pleasure thank you my
friend thank you and thank you guys for
tuning in that was Miko pillid you can
go ahead and read his book The General
son and why I mean if it was a
Palestinian or maybe a Muslim and Jordan
Peterson who's had Muslims on the
program and we commend you for that but
now you have a chance to redeem yourself
you get the message here
from an Israeli whose grandfather was
one of the original signers on this
piece of paper here for the creation of
the state and then you had his father
was a general an Israeli Army he's put
everything on the line you have so many
people and usually there'll be few of
those people because most of the people
they want to be led and they're being
led by Liars like this that now
academically you're an academic Jordan
Peterson you can go ahead and read this
book probably very quickly that he had
shared with us the four thousand year
history of Palestine
and you can bring on people like Miko
pilot so I need you guys out there to go
ahead so he's got no excuse
and recommend that Jordan Peterson
brings on
this man Miko pillitt on his show to go
ahead and do
the right for the wrong that he just did
advertising as he said Mikko people
haven't infectuation with this person
who's done so many horrific crimes
against humanity innocent children
so it's up to you now Miko I mean sorry
it's up to you mikko's ready it's up to
you Jordan Peterson and up to you guys
go ahead if you're a Palestinian if
you're a seeker of truth you're an
American and you want the truth out
there send this to Jordan Peterson right
now and petition and be a voice for him
to get Mikko pillid on his program to
talk about this on what's really going
on in this part of the world there's so
much history there
and inshallah we can do our small part
we'll see you next time until then
subscribe if you haven't already so you
can get all of the latest shows sent to
you
and we'll see you next time until then
peace be with you assalamu alaikum I
cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you're
tuning in to see what these Muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the Quran go and visit thedenshow.com
we'll take care of the postage and
everything and get it delivered to you
and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you and if you
like this episode of the dean show like
this video
share this video far and wide and
support us on our patreon page so we can
continue this work thank you for tuning
in peace be with you assalamualaikum